je m'appelle rémy sur représentant de
commerce
j'ai 24 ans je m'appelle claire csu
secrétaire nous une compagnie
d'assurance et sirènes d'un tel goût de
rien cette femme se fait pas
elle s'apprête à réaliser un de ses
fantasmes et préférez vous allez vous
habiller comment la série c'est tout ce
que je vais choisi à pul père qui est
très doux qui étend les nages qui était
assez excitant ensuite une petite jupe
très courte légère qui lui va très bien
c'est provoquant
[Musique]
le soir on descend d'un 22 23 heures
dessin du 14e étage on passe par le
parking on sort par un autre bâtiment
et puis on les sent au troisième
sous-sol mais la cctv troisième sous sol
de la gare 388 je les range retrouvent
le soir on était petit et parce que
parce qu'on a peur que quelqu'un nous
surprennent que quelqu'un vienne
chercher sa voiture ou quelque chose
dans sa cave un moment on entend des
bruits des parcs et puis ben harper oui
un peu
[Musique]
devenu